hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
heute zahlen neu delhi wie die ritschel
titel eingeblendete kollege block 23
zwar haben ich und marvin uns wieder
zusammengesetzt und einen block von
kollegen als ganzes allerdings startet
hier nochmal die bitte an euch erscheint
mich in die kommentare
das gemacht blabla deswegen verlinke ich
euch hier oben das making of gibt euch
das auf jeden fall mal das hatte aber
noch sagen kann hochgeladen der oben in
der beschreibung verlegt und jetzt film
ab mit ukulele blogs teil 3
ich bin jetzt
jetzt soll aber ich war noch duschen
hallo mein name so connelly ist colina
du bist also coli wir haben schon viel
von dir gehört
ich habe ihn als kleines mitgebracht das
ist aber lebt von deere co elena ist im
keller
du musst in rom gehen da bist du ja
warum ist das ihre dunkel
kannst du mir mal verraten dass du hier
machst
ich habe eine zeitmaschine gebaut damit
kannst du die zukunft und in die
vergangenheit reisen und die soll
funktionieren na klar du kannst ja
direkt mal testen
ich weiß nicht wo bist du wirklich
sicher dass sie funktioniert ich weiß
nicht nur toll jetzt schon funktionieren
festhalten
halo ist hier jemand nein nein nein
wird eine zeitmaschine und wer bist du
jetzt hallo mein name ist schon okay du
bist in der absoluten kombi
apokalyptischen gelandet und wir sollen
uns verteidigen
ich habe ein klein ich mich auf das ist
aus plastik
aber wir sind auch ukulelen stimmt dass
du das gehört ich habe doch keine oma
ich mache das nie wieder da bist du ja
wieder
wen hast du denn mitgebracht das ist so
noko zigarette zu uns und was machen wir
jetzt keine ahnung